hello everyone welcome back to our
Channel where we dive into the exciting
world of AI and programming today we
have a special treat for you we are
going to learn how to create a
customized version of Chad GPD using
Chad GPT itself so let's get started and
just a quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master artificial
intelligence and machine learning skills
skills and learn your dream job or grow
in your career then you must explore
simply learns cohort of various Ai and
ml programs simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like Von
Purdue keltech I kpur and many more and
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering explainable AI machine
learning algorithms and over a dozen
others and and that's not all you also
get the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in Top Tire product companies
and academicians from top universities
after completing these courses thousands
of Learners have transitioned into an AI
or ml role as a fresher or moved on to a
higher paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find an AI nml
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest
and now let's get started so first let's
understand what chat gbt is so chat gbt
is developed by open a and it's an AI
model that's designed to understand and
generate humanik text it's used for a
variety of applications from customer
service to creative writing but did you
know you can customize it for your
specific needs and now let's see how so
to start we first have to head over to
the chat gyy website and this is the
chat gbt website and now get to the
explore section so here you will find
resources and guidelines on how to
interact with and modify chat jbt make
sure you have an account and the
necessary access if required that is you
need gp4 for this that is the
subscription model and now onto the fun
part we can tailor chat GB to understand
specific Jon respond in a certain tone
or even train it on unique data sets and
you can see the other gpts and you have
or you must have been heard of that is
D data analysis chat jib Classic Game
Time The Negotiator creative writing
coach Cosmic dream so what does these
gpts do so Dal you just have to turn
your imagination into imag dream you
just have to write the text and it will
generate that text into the images so
this is about D and then we have data
analysis and these are the jbts that are
configured by the chat jbt only that
pass configured by open so data analysis
you just have to upload the files you
can upload any file the data file and it
will help you analyze and visualize your
data so this was about the data analysis
and similarly we have other gbts that is
CH jbt Classic this is the latest
version of jbt 4 with no additional
capabilities so this will only give you
the text answers and then we have game
time I can quickly explain board games
or card games to players of any age so
in this you can just ask him like how to
play chess and he will direct you or you
could upload any image of the game and
if you want to know which game is this
you could just upload the image and it
will tell you what image and what game
is this and it will direct you to all
the rules of that game and now we'll go
back to explore and here we'll create a
gbd so you can see that the GPD Builder
ask us hi I will help you build a new
GPD you can say something make a
creative who helps generate visuals for
new products or make a software engineer
who helps format my code what would you
like to make so this chat GPD Builder it
involves tweaking the models parameters
and training it with s simple dialogues
or text that align with your desired
output so let's try a simple example
here we will customize chgb to act as a
personal fitness assistant we'll feed it
information about different workouts
nutrition advice and motivational codes
watch as I input the data and adjust the
settings so first I want you to act as a
personal fitness
assistant
so you could see that the GPT Builder
it's updating the GPT according to a
command that we have provided it so you
could see that the GPT behavior is
adjusted and you could see the preview
here so great choice how about we name
this GPT Fitness Bud does that sound
good to you
yeah it's
great yeah it's
good so you could see that the GPT
Builder has named it and now he will
also uh what I remember like yeah it's
generating the profile picture so now it
will generate the profile picture for
our particular custom
GPD so you could see that here's the
profile picture for bit buddy what do
you think would you like any changes to
it so if you want to change this picture
you can just tell him that I want these
like settings or customizations in the
particular picture and the chat J will
do for you and if you want to upload
your own picture you can do that also
and you could see the preview here and I
am okay with this picture so I will just
write that it's good to go so the
picture is okay so JB Builder has said
great let's refine the context a bit
more when Fitness bu provides Fitness
advice should it focus more on beginner
level information or should be able to C
all levels from beginner to advance
like we will ask him it should C A all
that is from beginner to Advanced oh I
forgot the spelling of bner but yeah
bner to
Advanced so here you can see that the
GPT Builder is updating the custom GPT
for us that is Fitness bud and the GPT
Behavior has been updated now let's
think about the style of interaction
should Fitness bud have a friendly or
casual tone or a more formal and
professional demor how do we want it to
communicate with users so we
want a friendly and formal D we want it
both friendly and formal
D and here you can see that the GPT
Builder is updating the GPD for the tone
and you could see that the regarding the
kind of information fitness body
provides should it Focus solely on
excise and workout routines or should it
also include nutritional advice and
General Wellness tips yeah it
should cover all the
tips
and I
will
upload
some
transcript or
PDF to update the fitness
body
and you can
use that for advice okay here you could
see that the GPT Builder is updating the
GPT and we will upload some PDF or I
just have one PDF and it has many
articles or the content for the fitness
so we will upload that and gvt Builder
will upload that content and customize
our fitness body according to that and
according to that script only he will
answer us great fitness body shaving up
nicely next let's consider any specific
features or capabilities you would like
Fitness birday to have for example
should it have like should it be able to
create personalized worker plans or
track progress over time what additional
functionalities would you like to
include yeah it should be able to that
is like create personalized workout
plans to create
Bookout plans and now T
shape the
fitness
ready
and configure
it
finally okay so like this would be the
most probably the last question that JP
Builder will ask as we have concluded it
that configure it finally so gbt Builder
is updating the GPT so GPT Behavior
updated and fitness body is now fully
configured as your personal fitness
assistant ready to create workout plan
give nutrition advice and support your
Wellness Journey with a friendly yet
formal approach so here in the configure
section you could see that the name is
fitness body and this is the profile
pick of the fitness body that has been
created by the chat je only and this is
the description and the instructions
that is fit Fitness bu is an all
encompassing Personal Fitness assistant
capable of creating personalized workout
plans tailor to each user specific
Fitness levels and goals and this is how
it carry
on and these are the conversation
starters that how can I improve my
cardio and in the preview you can see
these if you want to update or don't
want these you could just cross them and
if you want to upload some files you
could upload and I have some data that
is
bodybuilding so I will upload this to
customize my gbt more and to have a
formal and professional tone that have
been contented in the building do
bodybuilding dopdf this will have the
same tone as mine so the capabilities we
have tick mark web browsing D image
generation if you want to like upload
any image and ask ask like which workout
is this so he the fitness body will be
able to like read the image and like
tell you all about that workout and if
you want to like take Mark code
interpretor you can do that so this was
the configuration and here we will ask
the chat jpd that I
have
uploaded a
file named bodybuilding dopdf if we just
yeah that's bodyb building.pdf
okay our
message
okay we write again that I have uploaded
a body
building PDF
file uh use that
file for Fitness bu
and
configure that for
me and use the
same
file
to
answer
the
questions so you could see that the GP
Builder is updating the GPT here and
here the GPT behavior is updated and
fitness body is now configured to use
the information from your bodybuilding
PDF file it can provide specialized
advice on bodybuilding and fitness
training based on this resource go ahead
and try Fitness part in the playground
to the right let me know if there are
any other adjustments or refinements you
would like to make so like this is the
playground where you could just and
while saving you could just publish it
to only me or only people with the link
where you could just send the link or
the public you want all of you to just
use your Fitness bu and you could just
confirm it
afterwards and here you could just ask
uh here I will ask I want to start my
fitness journey
so design a workout
plan
for me as a
bner okay let's
see so you could see that our fitness
bud has started to give us the whole
work plan that is Week 1 to 4 that is
the first month that is the foundation
phase and the workout structures are
warm up strength training cool down so
this is all about the workout plan and
once we have set up our model uh we are
testing it and we can ask various
Fitness related questions and see how it
responds and based on the responses only
we can further tweak the model to make
it more accurate and helpful so this is
how we can move more customize it and
make it perfect or accurate and now the
possibilities are endless for these
customizations so we can create a chat
GPT model for educational purposes as a
hobbist board for business analytics and
much more so this is how we make the
custom GPT using chat GPT only and you
could save it and confirm it so this is
our fitness buddy and you could create
your own
on what topic or on what configuration
you like so what's your idea for a
custom chat JP model share it in the
comment section below and that's how we
can create a customized version of chat
jpt using the tools provided by open AI
only and if you found this video helpful
please hit the like button and subscribe
for more content on AI and programming
and don't forget to hit the Bell icon to
stay updated until next time keep coding
and exploring the Limitless
possibilities of AI till then stay safe
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI I machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch s videos
to nerd up and get certified click
here